eu vou falar com vocês um pouquinho
sobre o papel da educação na formação do
profissional do futuro e pra isso eu
gostaria de falar com vocês sobre quatro
coisas
a primeira coisa é sobre a linha do
tempo
a segunda coisa é fazer shaking a
terceira fazer compras ea quarta sobre
samambaias horas só quatro coisas
aparentemente conexas mas avaliava elas
com o tempo
então quando a gente fala em
profissional do futuro a gente tem que
pensar que o futuro
nessa linha do tempo hoje a gente vai
ter um futuro amanhã mas hoje já é o
futuro de um tempo passado que a pessoa
fez foi o futuro de um tempo mais
passado então quando a gente vai olhando
na história do tempo a gente vê que a
ciência evoluiu arquitetura viu a
tecnologia e flamengo tudo mudou toda
cresceu mas chama coisas e manteve a
mesma ao longo de toda a história da
humanidade que o que é justamente o
homem nome ele é um homem ele é ser
humano desde o tempo da época frontal
até hoje
então quando a gente fala no
profissional do futuro a gente tá
pensando que é um nome que a única coisa
certa é constante que a gente tem porque
as tecnologias e latvala avançando e
mudando tão rapidamente que é difícil a
gente prevê o que vai ser amanhã eu sou
uma criança que tinha telefone com o
filho quando saiu o telefone sem fio já
foi uma novidade do tipo celular touch
pro a shine são de saltos gigantes que
não baixa de tempo tão curto acontece
então pensar no futuro
diante do olhar da tecnologia é quase
certo é difícil a gente falar mas a
gente colocando quanto o homem que a
constante ao longo do tempo é mais
incerto ea então vou falar só para fazer
check in
esse hábito tão corriqueiro veio fácil
a palestra na pet da chave e fez um
check in na hora não sei se tornando um
exemplo mas fazer um shake no
restaurante no shopping fazer um
shopping aqui é uma abstração começar já
te dissesse eu estava aqui
na verdade ela está aqui o ser humano
ele é por essência hoje online e limão é
online
só que a gente sabe extrai o tempo todo
por nós e do nosso está pra entrar no
online como se fosse uma linguagem mas
como eu tinha isso tudo foi mudando com
o tempo
só que essa questão da habitação ela é
tão corriqueira que a gente sabe extrai
o tempo todo e o que acontece quando a
gente vai trabalhar por exemplo a gente
veste a carapuça profissional sabe
extraindo share humana pelas chamas
muitas pensam professions se coloca
diante da sala de aula esquecendo que
ele não tinha já foi um aluno deixando
de colocar ele como um ser humano sendo
importador de voz daquela contando todo
que tem que ser transmitido
de acordo com o que ocorre quando o
programa que ele tem que transmitir
então o que acontece é uma abstração do
que quando o profissional ele se coloca
como ser humano diante de outro ser
humano
ele avalia o que eu estou dizendo que eu
estou fazendo isso tem importância mas
de certa forma esses profissionais hoje
em dia
perderam o direito de fazer isso porque
eles estão preocupados com o que como
aquilo que eles têm que cumprir
é uma abstração é fazer um check in no
papel de professor e de chats e ser
humano
então vou contar uma história bem
curtinha aqui é sobre o meu pai só pra
mim uma circulada torino como vocês
podem perceber essa primeira palavra que
eu falei isso ali na maternidade quando
minha parte descobriu que o show ainda
tinha uma época
e não tinha o trecho então acho peças
eram reservadas o pato
então meu pai e minha mãe descobrir um
shopping ainda assim que eu tinha lá
pela polinia choque um choque eo meu pai
que ainda não fazia check naquela época
ele era offline
ele estava ele ali sentada na sala de
espera da maternidade e ele estava ali
refletindo só pra fita dele só pra filha
dele que tinha acabado de nascer e que
aquilo ia ter que fazer pra chutar
aquela menina que ia precisar de ajuda e
trabalhou na vida dele e ele já tinha
dois filhos nossos irmão já era um
adolescente quando é assim a vida corria
bem uma vida acadêmica tradicional eles
já tinha livros escritos mas todos os
livros escritos com nota de rodapé com
linguagem acadêmica e eu estou falando
aqui com vocês e vocês estão me contra
entendo porque eu fala português e vocês
falam português
nós temos a mesma linguagem e para meu
pai está no meu coração ele passar pelo
que ele teria que falar a linguagem do
coração
não existe texto acadêmico que entre do
coração de alguém testes acadêmicos em
uma outra função
então junto com o meu nascimento marcelo
rubem alves que decidiu escrever de
forma diferente e aí pra mim a chutar
ela começou a escrever as histórias
infantis em pouco tempo depois
cinco anos depois do nascimento e
defendendo a livre-docência dele e aí
ele tinha segurança que ele não ia mais
ser permitido
então foi aí que ele parou de se
preocupar com o que os outros vão pensar
a respeito dele e ele criou coragem para
escrever no chão a alma dele foi aí
então que aconteceu a grande virada e
começou a sair atrás do outro quando a
gente olha ali entre 82 e 83 saíram está
e se reaproxima vez no ano de política
defendeu o livre
essência porque aqui é daí então ele
estava pronto e flecha ele offline
ele toma uma decisão de chopinzinho sem
nem que em nenhum livro nenhuma
referência em latim sei que caminho
tomar
e aí fui crescendo e vem uma obra do meu
pai crescendo e ele sempre me questionou
você vai cuidar da minha obra pra mim eu
dizia não exatamente mas chove já chama
arquiteta só tem três filhos mas nestas
instalar outra biólogo você tem é que
tata porque eu tenho que cuidar chopra
essa foi a resposta que eu tenho pra ele
a vida toda até começar a ver que o
século estava se encerrando que a morte
dele estava se aproximando e sem que nem
uma enciclopédia nenhum texto da
internet mids sms alguma orientação eu
comecei a perceber que eu tinha que
tomar alguma providência sinal todo o
legado do meu pai eu morrer junto com
ele e sei que ele me pedir city nova eu
comecei a militar e foi ali dois anos
antes do falecimento dele ea gente
decidiu fundar o instituto rubem alves
mesmo sem o saber direito para quem
recebe mas todos os anos depois em 2014
ele faleceu e foi ali no velório que eu
tomei uma decisão
da mesma forma que ele desse tio ali na
maternidade que ele está na flora ter
também assisti aqui eu ia me dá e que a
partir daquele momento não tinha mais
duas carreiras é o show off e online
eu tenho que estar inteira em um lugar e
já decidi então a partir daquele momento
que ia cuidar do instituto rubem alves
portanto por amor à minha posse se
transformou por amor a ele eu me
transformei quando a gente está inteiro
e offline
em algum lugar acreditando naquilo que a
gente faz e amanda aquilo que a gente
faz a gente faz coisas mais tantos
formadoras
então falei sobre a linha do tempo
sobre a consciência de que o homem é uma
constante e que para a gente ser
inovador nós temos que ser justamente
humanos
eu falei sobre a questão no check in que
a gente tem que lembrar que nós presença
chamas e offline
nós estamos aqui e agora é agora vai
falar sobre fazer compra
vamos para o supermercado
a gente pega ali as coisas que a gente
precisa para abastecer a despensa da
princesa xuxa precisa daquilo vale
analista de compra vaticano que já
comprei mas aí eu chego na seção de
vinhos e fala em acho que vai levar um
rio é porque é preciso não é porque é
pra seja porque eu quero o que eu gosto
da mesma forma se achou não comprar uma
roupa no shopping é uma completa falta
que é preciso uma ampla campanha roupa
que bateu prazer
tínhamos a e assim nós somos por
inteiras nosso conhecimento nosso
aprendizado
ele consiste em duas frentes
naquilo que a ferramenta naquilo que a
gente precisa e naquilo que está a fazer
fora essas duas frentes a gente engole e
depois esquece cobra conhecimento que a
gente tem que adquirir para passar no
vestibular e todo mundo aqui pode
afirmar por experiência própria que
esquece do que aquele conhecimento gente
adquire passar no vestibular
mas ele não tem nenhuma serventia na
nossa vida e ele não toca o nosso
coração
da mesma forma a gente aprende a dirigir
um carro daqui é uma ferramenta mas pode
ser um prazer
a gente aprende a escrever porque é uma
ferramenta pode trazer
então quando as coisas estão vinculadas
a uma utilidade e ao prazer
elas não são esquecidas fazer compras
essa matemática fazer compras se aplica
toda a nossa vida a toda a comunicação e
até a educação ambiental é necessário
um professor qualquer pessoa que esteja
comunicando algo para pensar eu estou
falando isso por quê e para quem
para o cedente addition vai contar uma
história bem pequenininha que a história
sobre cinco macacos um machado um cacho
de bananas e um grupo de psicólogos
tinha uma jaula cinco macacos dentro um
cacho de bananas pendurada num certo da
jaula embaixo do carro de totó cacho de
banana chega à mesa dos macacos e
olharam a mesa olhar a banana shopping
na mesa para pegar banana mas as
psicólogas estado nome da espanha essa
situação e quando isso aconteceu
jogaram uma ducha de água fria nos
macacos
totti levaram xisto passado chance outro
macaco pra tentar mas na classe chope na
mesa para pegar a banana outra ducha de
água fria
é tá aqui nessa janela que chove na mesa
para pegar pra não leva pra gente água
fria
então toda pés criou um macaco tentado
chope na mesa para pegar uma banana
o jc online batiam nele porque ninguém
queria levar um chute água gelada tom aí
as psicólogas tiraram um macaco e puxar
um outro francisquinho que nada sabia
tem um chat água gelada macaca fila
imensa fila cacho de banana é que ele
fez pela chapinha na mesa e deixou
outras foram lá e bateram nele e levamos
um susto tentar de novo a apanhar de
novo
é pá que chove na mesa nessa janela à
praia e assim acho que colegas foram
trocadas aos espetáculos tirar um outro
macaco e puxar o outro macaco novo chá
pela mesa e que levou uma chuva
inclusive daquele uma capa que nada
sabia sobre a taxa de água gelada e
depois de trocarem os cinco macacas
completamente repetir e se perguntar se
aproxima cacos do que é que fosse bater
nos outros quando ela shopping na mesa
eles irão responder por que aqui nessa
jaula
é assim que se faz então nós temos a
responsabilidade de não simplesmente
fazer uma coisa porque é assim que se
faz
nós somos humanos e offline e nós temos
compromisso com aquilo que nós estamos
passando para as outras pessoas
yang em uma frase que eu gosto muito que
ele diz
conheça todas as teorias tome todas as
técnicas mas ao tocar uma alma humana
seja apenas outra alma humana e isso é
falido através de todos os séculos e
continuasse continuará sendo válido
independente de onde a tecnologia nos
levar
e para encerrar eu vou falar pra
samambaias a samambaia assim como todas
as plantas elas mas em próton crescem e
raiz não se reproduza a gente morre é só
cerca de 30 delas elas não estavam
preocupadas em fazer a diferença
elas ficam olhando como se nada tivesse
acontecendo e pra gente fazer alguma
diferença no futuro a gente não pode se
comportar frente samambaia uma pessoa
que vem
cresce reprodutores e morre a gente tem
que se preocupar com a gata que a gente
ficar achando porque nós shams aqueles
seres que são seres humanos 10 da
história da humanidade nós estamos aqui
para fazer a diferença e quando a gente
se coloca no nosso senso humana a gente
pode fazer a diferença
então é isso que eu queria dizer pra
vocês muito obrigado